When you're trying to take ownership of a mistake made by a fellow team member,
what do you do if the team leader asked for a step by step,
step by step breakdown of events,
I'd said it was our mistake and not too,
and not made excuses,
but a step by step breakdown would expose the fact that he alone was responsible
for the air.
It's interesting.
So he basically gets interesting.
It is,
wait,
wait.
So he's basically saying,
okay,
it's our mistake,
right?
I don't want to individualize this guy or assault,
you know,
make him stand out or whatever.
Um,
it's our mistake and we're going to fix it kind of thing.
And he's like,
no,
I want to step by step,
step,
step by steps.
Gonna reveal,
reveal the Solo.
Actually bill's fault.
And now what I do,
I
tried so hard to take ownership but here's the part,
it was actually built.
It was all jacked up.
Actually not mine.
Not My fault is what we're saying.
It's,
it's the truth,
right?
You get that right.
Yeah.
Cause cause check it out.
Who's responsible leaders.
When you're taking ownership of something,
when you're taking extreme ownership of something,
whose fault is it?
Your mind?
Yeah,
sure.
Is that include when someone else on your team makes a mistake?
Yes,
but how can that be God's man?
It's here.
It's your team.
So let me ask you these questions.
Here's what I'd be thinking.
Um,
the teammate was in error.
Why or why did the teammate make a mistake?
Why didn't the teammate have backup?
Why didn't the rest of the members of the team,
why didn't I actually go through with him and make sure that he knew how to do
that procedure properly?
He's part of my team.
We're responsible for this taking place.
I knew he was a little bit shaky and I didn't do anything to fix it.
That's why it's our fault.
It's not our fault because we say,
oh,
it's our fault,
but it's really,
Bill.
That's not,
that's not what we're talking about.
The point is,
the point is to actually own it.
So if my coworker fails,
I'm literally saying to myself,
what mistake did I make that my coworker dropped the ball?
What mistake did I make?
My coworker dropped the ball.
Did I not show it to them?
Did I not ask him if he knew how to do it?
Did I not ask me if he needed some help?
Did I not confirm that he knew the procedures correctly?
All those things are my fault.
Did I not do a good job of identifying that bill was a little bit slow on the
uptake and therefore he needed a little extra preparation for this
and now,
now think about this.
What can I do once I make those mistakes?
Okay,
we're going to do to fix them.
Now think about this from a leadership perspective.
You go down and you say,
Hey,
you guys,
you guys messed up this thing.
Why did it happen?
And now think about the team where everyone goes,
well,
you know it's our fault.
Mostly Bill,
right?
And I'll tell you when I,
when,
when I look at a platoon and bill made a mistake,
I don't look at bill.
A good leader doesn't just look at bill.
A good leadership looks at everyone on the team,
especially certainly the leadership,
but I think this guy's talking about from a peer,
but it doesn't matter from a peer perspective,
if there's a mistake that happens,
we are truly responsible.
And then from a leadership perspective,
when I go down to the team and I say,
hey guys,
what happened?
And they said,
well it was our fault,
but this is what bill did.
I go,
okay,
so you just dropping dime on bill.
I'm not going to say that,
but I'm like,
I'm thinking to myself,
okay so it's all bill's fault.
Cool.
I'll tell you what.
Whereas if you say,
hey listen,
bosses,
what happened?
Here's the procedures that we went.
I don't think we did a good job of briefing bill.
Cause here's what bill did.
He,
he did step three instead of step for my fault.
We went through twice.
But why should have gone through it a couple more times and confirm he knew what
was going on.
It's not gonna happen again.
We got this.
Which guy are you wanting to work for?
Which guide you,
which,
which team do you want?
You want the team where people are taking ownership of the problem,
not blaming bill.
Ah,
ownership is not just saying we own it.
Ownership isn't actually owning it.
And that's what makes it so powerful.
What makes it so powerful is if you actually own it,
then you actually look at bill beforehand and you go look in our team.
Do we have any weaknesses?
Yeah,
we do.
We got bill build.
Doesn't bill can't get this part of the procedure done right?
Here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna put bill into this other position.
That's an easier part of the procedure or to make sure he knows how to do that.
Meanwhile,
we're taking Mike and Mike is going to go down here and he nails this procedure
and he's going to spend,
by the way,
an extra 15 minutes a day during lunch,
he's going to get bills trained up.
So bill can eventually do,
that's the good thing you'd do on a team.
Yeah.
You made it pretty clear who's,
um,
which is kind of,
cause it's not that easy to understand or it wasn't for me anyway.
I mean put it this way,
it was,
it was very valuable.
One,
I didn't understand this about extreme ownership.
I said this before too,
by the way.
So there's,
there's essentially two parts of it that make it extreme ownership.
Actually there's three,
there's the dichotomy,
but aside from the dichotomy,
this is what it is.
You take responsibility and then you say what you're going to do to fix it.
The problem.
And then actually there's a third part,
which is you implement the solution.
Yes,
yes.
Okay.
You identify it,
you own the problem,
you identify a solution for the problem,
and then you implement the solution.
Yes.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
So a lot of times in the be,
especially in the beginning,
like I would just be as far as me just kind of casually trying to understand it,
I would focus so much on taking responsibility,
you know,
it was my fault,
kind of thing.
It's like,
well,
they're taking responsibility.
I mean is arguably more important than saying that it's your fault kind of
thing.
It's essentially you're,
you're taking responsibility of the solution as well.
If not in a way,
in a lot of practical cases,
you don't even have to identify who's fault it is.
If you take responsibility of the solution,
like if,
if I'm okay here.
So if there's a football
team,
right,
that's like the epitome of team,
not the epitome,
but what a good example of teamwork.
Nevermind the seal teams or whatever,
but we'll go with it.
Well,
football is pretty soon it'll be more simple because it's,
so let's say,
okay,
we've got to pass or whatever,
and boom,
the play,
the play starts and a guy gets through the front line.
Uh,
let's say the guard missed a block.
Obvious,
right?
He missed it.
Maybe he looked one way and it was supposed to look this way.
You supposed to not pull any tried to pull or something.
Maybe he just made a mistake.
He just made a mistake.
He's not in company.
Just made a mistake.
Whose fault is it?
The guards fall.
Okay.
But if the quarterback's going to take extreme ownership,
he's going to be like,
Hey,
no problem.
this happened.
You know,
next time I'm going to remind them,
hey,
on this play that play,
you know,
this red 46,
no curve twist or whatever you like,
you don't pull.
And he pro probably be like,
oh man,
I know,
I know it.
Don't go to scold them.
Just be like,
hey,
you don't go,
no problem,
but we're just not going to do that anymore.
And then next time I call that play and be like,
you're good.
Right.
I'm gonna check with them.
I didn't check with him that first time you made a mistake.
My check with them,
he won't make that mistake again.
And like when we are now becoming her driving,
he's me.
You know,
it's kind of one of those things.
The quarterback took responsibility for solving the problem more so than he was
like,
okay,
loops.
Um,
that was my fault.
I made a big deal out of it being his fault,
even though in his head it is,
you know,
it's like,
okay,
this is my fault.
I should,
you know,
I should make sure things are clear kind of thing.
Like the weather too.
You know your weather.
Yeah.
Well what bothers me the most about this question is I feel like,
I feel like I don't do a good job of explaining this because what bums me out as
someone,
whoever wrote this question and it's a good question.
I get the question,
I get scared that the person that's listening to the question goes now Jocko
doesn't quite get it.
He doesn't quite get the fact that there was this one guy who is part of the
team who made this mistake and no one,
you know we just,
we can't hold his hand every time.
Like that's not my fault.
It's not our team's fault.
When bill drop completely drops the ball.
That's not my fault.
It's not anyone on the team's fault.
And my point is is exactly what you are saying.
Echo.
Yes it is.
And if you look at it,
when bill makes the mistake himself,
he's alone in a room and he supposed to,
you know,
he supposed to put part a on top of part B and Bolt them together.
That's his part of the job.
He's alone in a room doing that and he doesn't do it right.
That's 100% his fault.
The answer is no actually who's in charge of training him?
Who's in charge of checking,
who not even in charge of WHO's responsible.
We are a team.
That means we work together.
That means we confirm that we know how to do our individual parts of the job.
That means we check and say,
hey bill,
are you good?
Hey Bill,
let me check your first three that you do to make sure you understand what's
happening.
We do this together as a team and it makes me feel like a failure.
That people have a hard time understanding this and,
and I know it's,
it can be a stretch,
it can be a stretch and you know,
I give all those examples,
hey,
the machine gunner shoots in the wrong direction.
Who's fault is that?
It's not the machine.
The machine gunner literally pointed the machine gun in the wrong direction,
pulled the trigger and shot in the wrong direction.
Who's fault is it?
It's the squad leaders.
It's the fire team leaders.
It's the platoon leaders because they didn't make sure that he understood his
field of fire.
Make sure he understood how to operate his weapon.
And by the way,
there's a chance that the reason that bill screwed this up and bill is incapable
of putting these parts together correctly.
And if that is the situation,
guess what?
It is the responsibility of the team to either get him trained up to where he
can't do it or to tell the leadership that this guy cannot these incapable of
doing the job and therefore he needs to not be here.
That's what ownership is.
That's what extreme ownership is.
I think I know what it is.
What,
what,
what makes it confusing or sometimes kind of kind of slippery like to grasp,
you know,
cause it depends on who you ask.
So a lot of times the thing is when,
when it's the machine gun,
his fault.
The thing is if I'm,
if I'm not even a human being,
I'm just the disembodied brain.
Okay,
it's the machine that is fault and the leader's fault and that it's everyone's
fault if I'm,
you know,
but,
but if you ask the individual person,
cause he asked the machine gunner,
hey,
okay Jocko,
you're the machine gun and you shot in the wrong direction.
And I asked you who's fault is that?
What are you going to say now leaders will,
well it's your fault.
No,
well let me,
let me tell you right now,
there are plenty of people and definitely plenty of machine gunners that when
they shoot that weapon in the wrong direction,
you know what they say?
I didn't get a clear brief on what the field to fired where no one until I
didn't see the,
the markers for what the range limits were.
I didn't know where the other blue forces were.
No one told me.
So they're looking at it like it actually isn't their fault.
Now you get some good machine.
And actually guess what?
When you have a guy that's a machine gunner that says,
what was my fault?
It was my leader's fault.
You know what the leader says?
What good is this?
A bad leader,
the leader in this team,
the leader in this team?
You know what he says?
No.
It was the machine gunners flop.
Yeah,
that's right.
And now guess who's fault it was?
It was no one's fault.
Yeah.
The machine gunner thing is the boss's fault.
The boss thinks it was a machine gunner his fault.
Now who's going to fix the problem?
The answer is no one.
No one.
Yeah.
When you get a good team,
the machine going to goes to my fault,
I should have paid better attention of leaders is my fault.
I sh and now you have every one taking ownership of the problems.
Yes.
Yeah,
and that's the way it's supposed to be,
but that's my point and that's why it makes it so nevermind.
You're destined body brain,
that's making decisions over here.
I'm saying this is why it's hard for people to understand.
That's why sometimes,
and I'm with them.
I'm like,
I was there.
It's kind of like,
hmm.
sure I'm tricking.
Extreme ownership,
you know,
the typical,
I'm taking extreme ownership at the end of the day,
we all know as well,
some bills for fault,
but the reason that it is
so hard because if I ask,
okay,
we have three guys,
one of those guys as a machine gunner,
the other guy's a leader,
the other guys,
just another team member.
Uh,
he's,
you know,
he's the,
the sniper or something.
If I say,
Hey,
this machine that a shot in the wrong direction,
individual meetings,
I,
they all take extreme ownership.
All of them are down there in the game.
All of them.
I asked you machine gunner,
who's fault is that?
What's he going to say?
You're my fault.
Okay,
next guy who's fault it fires you my fault.
I should've done.
And the squad leader,
my fault,
I should have told them,
right?
Yes.
So it the re now go back to the disembody brain.
It's kind of like,
wait,
wait.
So it's like he did it.
It's hard to grasp.
Like that one guy,
it is his fault thing.
It's not just his fault apparently,
because everyone said it's their fault.
Right.
So he was obviously his fault by weight.
It's everyone's fault kind of thing.
So when you're the guy and you're saying,
okay,
his fault it,
that little thing creeps in your brain that's like,
yeah,
wait,
it is his fault.
Yeah.
You know,
you and your team.
Yeah,
yeah.
And you're wrong.
And I'd need to do a better job of explaining that to people because I see
questions like this on a fairly regular basis,
which is,
hey,
really?
You know,
there's like,
Hey,
I get ownership.
But really?
Yeah,
that's what it means.
The,
but really that you need to check yourself on.
Yeah.
Because the reality is you're responsible.
You wait,
but if I'm responsible,
what about the machine that he just said he's responsible machine gunner.
You're was,
I'm,
no,
but the machine gunner said he's responsible.
See what I'm saying though?
I think that's the feeling that that Jeff,
you went that creep in and that's going to be a problem.
Yeah.
Probably ever seen office space.
Remember that?
Okay,
I have seen that.
So really when you think about,
okay,
what's the big thing that he has the movie remember is you okay,
let me,
let me remind you.
Okay.
So in the beginning they were like,
Hey Peter,
you were putting cover sheets on the tps reports from now on or we've been doing
that.
You forgot to do that,
right?
So first lumbered comes,
his boss for slumbered comes,
he's like,
yeah,
you know,
saying,
Hey,
let me read.
He didn't do it in a dick way.
Annoying for sure.
But he said,
hey,
this is basically a reminder.
Did you get that memo?
We're putting cover sheets on the tps particularly,
I just forgot it was the one time thing,
no problem.
And he's like,
cool,
all that,
you know.
So if you just do that,
do that,
that'd be cool.
And he's like,
cool,
no problem.
You saw,
I'll even give you another copy of that memo.
He almost like over did it.
Not almost.
He did overdo it.
So he left.
And then the other boss boom,
who's like one level down,
he came.
Same deal.
Hey,
we're putting,
did you get that memo?
TPS reports,
cover sheets now,
blah,
blah.
He's like,
I got the memo.
I forgot one time thing.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm just,
all those bosses were do,
doing,
making sure the problem got solved,
right.
Doing everything in their power.
Even his other,
his friends were like,
Hey,
what's up?
I heard you guys,
you're having problems with your tps.
So they were just taking extreme ownership,
taking ownership of the problem,
trying to solve it.
But we give them crap about it.
Who Do?
Who
Do we give a movie in a movie somewhere?
Yeah.
Yeah,
because they're trying to make it funny duty.
I know.
I know,
but that's kind of comedy,
but yeah,
I know.
But it's ironic,
right?
It is.
Yes.
So I'm not even mad at lumber for that listing.